cette saison dans la flamme 13 femmes
vont devoir se battre pour le coeur d'un
[ __ ] réactivation des petits boutons
aller alors marc la femme de votre vie
vous l'imaginez comment elle doit être
belle je m'appelle soraya j'ai 28 ans
daisy alexandra je suis juste à la
recherche de l'amour qu'ils aient de la
conversation c'est quoi ta plus grande
peur et puis il faut que je fasse rire
j'aime rire comme armor tabac vous même
on peut presque est ce que vous êtes
vous et de l'autodérision menons
d'accord non pas du tout qu'espérez-vous
le supplée dans la motion mais l'amour
est imprévisible
allez il peu échauffés les querelles en
mai et c'est sûr mais aussi que vous
voulez sur son passage au quai alexandra
c'était drôle non sentez-vous ridicule
et des lipides et tu vas me paie ses
compotes à l'eau j'ai foutu pc désactivé
je peux donc je n'ai pas pu arrêter de
me suivre la suite parmi ces 13
prétendantes
à qui marc déclara-t-il
sa flamme comment ça va - ouais super et
laventure huleux catastrophe